the coronavirus has transformed the
world were empty streets and shuttered
businesses are the norm and billions are
under lockdown but researchers around
the world are developing tests and
conducting clinical studies to explore
if people who have been infected and
cured are no longer at risk the aim is
to eventually allow people to go back to
normal life
the idea behind us is that if people get
immune through natural infection they
would have a similar situation to
someone having received a vaccination
and we could use antibody tests as soon
as proper antibody tests become
available we could use antibody tests to
document that immunity exists Britain
which is struggling to speed up testing
has floated the idea of a so-called
immunity Passport a certificate for
those who've recovered and declared
immune to the virus in the Veneto region
of Italy infected doctors and nurses are
being tested to see if they've developed
resistance to the virus so they can
return to work and millions more
Italians will be tested for natural
antibodies but it's unclear just how
reliable and effective the tests are
we're so early in the there are a small
number of people you know comparatively
who had been infected and have cleared
and we'll have both the antibodies but
we don't know for how long these
antibodies will last over what period of
time as and all antibodies will tend to
drop off with time at a time when
government lock downs have dropped so
many people of their livelihoods
they also concerns about criminals
forging immunity documents this passport
can be the equivalent of yellow fever or
polio certificates that allow
international travel to resume if
countries recognize such a certificate
but there will be a problem that I see
that it's around counterfeit certificate
because individuals communities urgently
want to return to economic activity
there are also difficult ethical
questions about whether such
certificates will cause more prejudice
and further restrict the most vulnerable
in society you can ensure that people
face lower risks and will reduce the
death toll from this but you have to
make more decisions about you know who
will be allowed to work and who won't be
who will be allowed to travel who won't
be the idea attractive and hopeful
perhaps but also fraught with
uncertainties as the world honker town
for yet another day of the global
pandemic Priyanka Gupta al-jazeera